let me ask
uh what is the meaning of life
the meaning of life you know from a
cosmologist's perspective or from a
human perspective
from my personal you know life is what
you make of it really
right it's um each of us has to have our
own
meaning and it doesn't have to be
well i think that in many cases meaning
is is to some degree associated with
goals you set some goals or expectations
for yourself
things you want to accomplish things you
want to do
things you want to experience and to the
degree that you
experience those and do those things it
can give you meaning
you don't have to change the world the
way
newton or michelangelo or da vinci did i
mean people often say
change the world but look come on
there's seven and a half close to eight
billion of us now
most of us are not going to change the
world and does that mean that most of us
are leading meaningful lives
no it just has to be something
that gives you meaning that gives you
satisfaction
that gives you a good feeling about what
you did and and often
based on human nature which can be very
good and also very bad
but often it's the things that help
others
that give us meaning and a feeling of
satisfaction
you taught someone to read you cared for
someone who was terminally ill
you brought up a nice family you brought
up your kids
um you did a good job you you put your
heart and soul into it
you read a lot of books if that's what
you wanted to do had a lot of
perspectives
on life you you traveled the world if
that's what you wanted to do
um but if some of these things are not
within reach
you're in a socio-economic position
where you can't travel the world or
whatever
you find other forms of of meaning
uh it doesn't it it doesn't have to be
some profound i'm gonna change the world
i'm gonna be the one who everyone
remembers
type thing right in the context of the
greatest story ever told like the fact
that we
came from stars
and now are two apes asking about the
meaning of life yeah
how does that fit together
how does that make any sense you know it
does it does and this is sort of what i
i was referring to that it's a beautiful
universe
that allows us to come into creation
right it's a way that the universe found
of knowing of understanding itself
because
i don't think that you know inanimate
rocks and stars and black holes and
things
have any real capability of of abstract
thoughts and of learning about
the rest of the universe or even their
origins i mean they're just they're just
a pile of atoms that's
that's has no conscience has no ability
to think
has no ability to explore and we do
and you know i'm not saying we're the
epitome of all
life forever but at least for life on
earth
so far the evidence suggests that we are
the epitome
in terms of the richness of our thoughts
the degree to which we can explore the
universe do experiments
build machines understand our origins
and i just hope
that we use science for good
not evil and that we don't end up
destroying ourselves i mean the whales
and dolphins
are plenty intelligent they're they
don't
ask abstract questions they don't read
books but on the other hand they're not
in any danger of destroying themselves
and everything else
as well and so maybe maybe that's a
better form of intelligence but at least
in terms of our ability to explore
and make use of our minds i mean
to me it's this it's this that
gives me um the potential for meaning
yeah
right the fact that i can understand and
explore
it's kind of fascinating to think that
the universe created us
and eventually we've built telescopes to
look back at it
to look back at its origins and to
wonder
how the heck the thing works it's
magnificent
needn't have been that way right and
this is one of the you know the
multiverse sort of things
you know you can alter the laws of
physics or or even the constants of
nature
seemingly inconsequential things like
the mass ratio of the proton and the
neutron
you know wake me up when it's over right
what could be more boring
but it turns out you play with things a
little bit like the ratio of the mass of
the neutron to the proton
and you generally get boring universes
only hydrogen or only helium or only
iron you don't even get the rich
periodic table
let alone bacteria paramecia slugs and
humans
okay i'm not even anthropomorph
anthropocentrizing this
to the degree that i could even a rich
periodic table
wouldn't be possible if if certain
constants weren't this way
but but they are and that to me
leads to the idea of a multiverse that
you know the dice were thrown many many
times and
there's this cosmic archipelago where
most of the universes are
are boring and some might be more
interesting but we are in the rare breed
that's really
quite darn interesting and if there were
only one and maybe there is only one
well then that's that's truly amazing
we're lucky
we're lucky but i actually think there
are lots and lots just like there are
lots of planets
earth isn't special for any particular
reason there are lots of planets in our
solar system and especially around other
stars
and occasionally there are going to be
ones that are conducive to the
development of complexity
culminating in life as we know it and
that's a beautiful
story
you